wir haben es auch gerade gehört die
bayern sind geteilter meinung was sagen
sie als experte wie schätzen sie denn
diesen zehn punkte plan ein also
grundsätzlich geht das ganz klar die
richtige richtung oder wir müssen
unbedingt etwas tun nicht nur in bayern
ich hoffe dass wir zu einheitlichen
regeln kommen werden hoffentlich
vielleicht noch in dieser woche denn uns
ist ehrlicherweise gesagt die also
pandemie hier in deutschland im moment
etwas aus der kontrolle geraten die
gesundheit sagt haben die vernichter
nachverfolgen 400 bis 500 tote pro tag
kein ende in sicht das können wir so
nicht weiter akzeptieren was ist nicht
zu verantworten daher über die einzelnen
nach samen kann man diskutieren aber
dass etwas wirklich substanzielles jetzt
passieren muss es ganz klar
dann lassen sie uns genau über eine
maßnahme diskutieren in diesen zehn
punkte plan und zwar geht es um die
ausgangssperre von 21 bis 5 uhr in den
hotspots meinen sie das bringt überhaupt
war es um ehrlich zu sein um diese
uhrzeit ist man doch eigentlich gerade
eh nicht mehr draußen oder ehrlich
gesagt ist es zum teil anders wir haben
hier zum beispiel in köln aber und hier
in anderen städten gesehen dass dann
abends noch glühwein getrunken wurde das
was ich danach noch für zu hause
verabschiedet hat und ich glaube daher
dass die privaten feiern schon noch so
eine große rolle spielt ich glaube dass
wir meinen privaten feiern etwas machen
müssen ich glaube aber nicht dass wir
damit allein über die runden kommen
man muss sich überlegen die
weihnachtsferien vorzuziehen und
vielleicht auch zu verlängern war es
geschehen in den schulen ist nicht
wirklich also beruhigend und ist auch
zum teil 1 mit treiber der pandemie und
wir müssen uns auch überlegen ob es sinn
macht die geschäfte nach weihnachten
sofort wieder zu öffnen dann haben wir
vielleicht ganz viele zugänge durch die
fußgängerzone und berate treffen um den
einkauf herum zwischen weihnachten und
neujahr darum dass das auch weiter das
risiko erhöht dass wir sogar noch
steigen der fahrt zahlen für das neue
jahr bekommen
also herr lauterbach ich höre dass bei
ihm so ein bisschen raus soll jetzt ganz
deutschland dem clan von söder folgen
nein nicht im plan sind wieder ungefähr
also sondern wir müssen etwas
beschließen dass also der situation auch
in anderen bundesländern gerecht wird
und ich glaube der talschaft den wir
jetzt haben müssen wir also da müssen
wir ehrlich sein erreicht so nicht das
heißt wir brauchen bundesweit brauchen
wir schärfere regeln sollten wir eher
früher als später beschließen person
kann es nicht weitergehen wir können uns
nicht daran gewöhnen dass 400 bis 500
menschen jeden tag unnötigerweise nicht
haben und wir sehen sogar noch eine
schleife steigende tendenz das ist nicht
richtig
fordern sie also einen härteren lockdown
ja das würde ich so sagen also ich finde
ein herz doch dann das den derzeitigen
also scheint also wichtig weil wenn wir
nicht wenn wir es nicht machen dann
bleibt es dabei dass 400 bis 500
menschen pro tag sterben wir haben dann
bis ende januar ein und sieht keine
besserung in aussicht
das könnte sich sogar noch verschlimmern
über die feiertage daher glaube ich dass
was jetzt beschlossen ist
einschließlich der regelung bis zum 10
januar das wird so nicht ausreichen
wir müssen dann noch einmal überlegen ob
wir die ferien vollziehen und die ferien
verlängern und dort wie auch die
geschäfte wieder öffnen wollen nach
weihnachten
ich hatte das persönlich einfach für zu
gefährlich und willkommen so einfach
nicht aus diesen vielen zahlen aus sie
müssen bedenken auf jeden tag stirbt
kommen viele andere die bleibende
gesundheitliche beeinträchtigungen
vielleicht auch behinderungen
davontragen
herr lauterbach dann lassen sie uns
jetzt auch das ist auch ein wichtiges
thema für einige deutsche über das
reisen jetzt über die
weihnachtsfeiertage sprechen
immer wieder hört man ja mensch man kann
auf die kanaren fliegen da ist der
inzidenz wert sehr niedrig da es ist ja
vielleicht sogar sicherer als hier in
der hauptstadt zum beispiel was sagen
sie kann man bedenkenlos jetzt verreisen
über weihnachten bedenkenlos kann man
das auf keinen fall ich finde es zum
beispiel auch bedenklich dass man in
deutschland jetzt also bei
familienbesuchen den die hotels
absteigen kann
da wird immer argumentiert dass es also
sicher wäre in hotels übernachten
nastase zu übernachten ich glaube dass
es noch besser wäre wenn man wirklich
die weihnachtsfeier noch ganz kleine
kreise reduziert weil wir wollen ein
fest der nächstenliebe und sich
gegenseitig bewerten
reisen auf die kanarischen inseln also
dorthin zu reisen im land der
organisation
das sind alles risiken und wir sind
jetzt in einer besonders kritischen
situation und sterben im moment pro tag
mehr menschen was in der ersten welle wo
wir bereit gewesen sind viel
drastischere maßnahmen zu erhalten
ich bedanke mich bei ihnen für ihre sehr
klaren worte das sagte spd
gesundheitsexperte karl lauterbach schön
abend ihnen mehr nachrichten um breaking
news nur bei bate schau dir hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren